Male: In our earlier justifications
for an upward sloping
aggregate supply curve in the short run,
we kind of viewed price as
the independent variable.
What I want to explore a
little bit in this video
is that you could view
it the other way around.
You could view that real
GDP is driving price.
Just to review, this
is our upward sloping,
the thing that we want to happen.
Aggregate supply in the short run.
In the previous videos we said, hey,
when price increases,
this would cause real GDP
to maybe expand even beyond its potential,
beyond its natural rate.
Let's say that this is
where it is in the long run,
right over here.
Let me draw it.
This is where it is in the long run,
right over here.
This is an aggregate
supply in the long run.
This is the current level of prices.
This is all review.
Right over here, this is
our current level of prices.
This is where we're sitting on GDP.
In the past we said, hey,
if we increase prices
because of a bunch of
factors, that might cause,
in aggregate, the economy to produce even
above its natural rate,
so you would actually have
real GDP expanding, so you have
an upward sloping aggregate supply curve.
We gave reasons why price
might drive this to happen.
We talked about the misperception theory,
that individual actors in the economy,
individual firms, might misperceive
the increases in prices as a microeconomic
phenomenon and so they would,
because of the law of supply,
they'd think they were
making more real profit.
It would take them some time
to realize that they aren't.
It's just nominal profits
that they're getting.
On top of that, we talked about the whole
sticky wage, sticky cost theory,
that some part of the
economy there will be
increased real profits
because in the short term,
some players' costs aren't going to go up
as much as their revenue are,
so they would also want to essentially
produce more beyond their
natural productivity
and maybe overheat their factories
and their people a little bit.
But I want to talk in this video,
and this is true of a
lot of economic models,
you don't have to view
price as driving real GDP.
You could really just view
it the other way around.
As real GDP, if you get
utilization really, really high,
approaching 100%,
and depending on how
you define utilization,
maybe going even above 100%,
that that might actually drive prices,
or that maybe they are driving each other.
One way to think of it, and really this is
just another justification
for an upward sloping
aggregate supply curve,
but we're just doing it a different way.
Now we're saying this is our
natural rate of productivity.
If we're asking people to produce more,
then they're going to want to charge more.
The way to think about
this, and at the end
it's really not going to help them
because everything's going
to get more expensive.
They're going to produce more
but they're not going to,
on a per unit basis, not
get much more real profit.
But in the short run they might,
or they might think they are,
so they might want to do it.
The one way to think about this is
if you view this bar,
the area of this bar,
as the capacity of a firm,
the capacity of a market,
capacity of an entire economy,
then maybe its natural, its potential,
maybe it's sitting here
at maybe 85% utilization.
If the factory could be
producing widgets or cars
or whatever 100 hours a week, its natural
state is it's actually only producing
85 hours a week and
that's because it needs
to use that other 15
hours to let the factory
cool down, or to do
repairs and maintenance
or inspections of some sort.
But let's say that for whatever reason,
maybe a war starts, and the government
demands that more things get built,
more widgets get built,
more tanks get built,
more materials need to be developed,
that they're essentially
asking people not to do
some of these things that
they would have to do
if they want to be
sustainable in the long run,
and they ask the
factories to produce more,
to start getting to 90%, 95%,
maybe even 100% utilization.
You can imagine in this situation all of
the firms ... a firm
is all about maximizing
profit ... they will
raise prices when they
can raise prices even
though in the long run
it will just be a nominal increase.
It won't necessarily be a real increase,
but they'll feel in the
short run that it is
kind of a real increase in prices,
and so they will do that.
Instead of them trying
to build more capacity,
they might even view it
as a short run thing,
so they'll say, hey,
no, you're going to have
to pay us a lot of money for our employees
to work overtime.
Maybe that's even in some of the contracts
that you have to pay more
for them to work overtime,
for me to defer some of my maintenance
and other things that I
was going to going to do,
or kind of defer investment for me to just
produce all out right over here.
I'm just describing the
same upward sloping curve
but with a different narrative.
Instead of saying that price
is driving real GDP expansion
because of the misperception
theory and sticky prices,
I'm saying that an increase in real GDP
and an increase in
utilization will drive prices.
They're just two ways to
look at the same thing.
You can even apply that
to some of the ideas
that we talked about in the last video.
In the last video, you might
not have even had to resort
to the Aggregate Demand
Aggregate Supply model.
You might not even need
Aggregate Demand Aggregate
Supply to understand
why we had inflation in 1966 and 1967
and really the late '60s generally.
All you would have to do is think about
entering into, or the beginning of LBJ's
administration, the economy was already
at high utilization.
Unemployment was only at around 4% or 5%;
95%-96% of the labor force was employed.
Factories were operating
at high utilization.
Now we escalate the war.
We're taking people who could have been
employed in the domestic economy
and they're going and fighting in battle.
We need bullets, we need boats,
we need fuel, we need all of these things.
We need to utilize more
of domestic capacity
to produce all of these things, so you can
imagine that this dynamic was occurring;
that you had to get firms
and people to tap out
all of their extra
capacity, and then to do so
they're essentially going to demand
higher wages and higher prices.
We wouldn't have necessarily
even had to resort
to this to predict this higher inflation.
Another way to think about
it is this is another
way to justify an upward sloping
aggregate supply curve in the short run,
which is another way that we
described the same dynamic.
They're all heavily, heavily related.